kim jong-un
is the world's most dangerous dictator
boss of a ruthless communist dynasty
that has ruled north korea for 75 years
there is this perception that he is a
cartoon character kind of doctor evil
villain right
but kim jong-un really is no joke
he is a ruthless dictator hellbent on
staying in power
early in his rule kim jong-un wiped out
his enemies
then supercharged his nuclear arsenal
but kim's greatest challenge lies ahead
the world is changing to survive kim
must change with it and bring his
country into the modern age
how far can he stray from what his
father and his grandfather have created
in trying to portray himself as a modern
leader
without losing control
[Music]
[Music]
more provocation from the rogue nation
of north korea as new reports surface
that pyongyang is preparing for its next
nuclear test north korea showing the
world its new intercontinental ballistic
missile this comes after president trump
said a major conflict with north korea
is possible
little rocket man
we can't have mad men
out there
shooting rockets all over the place
[Music]
in 2017
kim jong-un achieved his family's
long-standing ambition
developing a nuclear missile capable of
striking north korea's mortal enemy
the united states
my name is jung pak i used to work at
the cia on korea issues
the premier product that we would
produce is the president's daily brief
which i wrote often
the toughest part is leadership
intentions
[Music]
when it comes to what's in somebody's
mind that is the most difficult part
i spent my entire career trying to crawl
inside kim jong-un's head
what we learned is that not only was he
an apt student of the legacy of his
grandfather and father but that he was
also bigger badder and bolder in terms
of how aggressive he was
[Music]
the missiles and his weapons are now
more powerful more dangerous more
reliable and more mobile
and that's what makes north korea under
kim jong-un a much scarier place and a
much scarier adversary
[Music]
but kim has a problem
cut off from the outside world his
country's economy is on its knees
north korea has been facing u.s
sanctions since the korean war
and they've just gotten progressively
tougher and tougher
so it's a real struggle
i think for kim jong-un to
push his country forward
this is a country that has chronic food
shortage it's isolated from the outside
world kim jong-un knows that in the long
run it's untenable for him to provide
for his people
to bring his country into the modern age
and maintain his grip on power
kim must lift the us-led sanctions
banning international trade with north
korea
in 2018
he makes his opening move
on june 12th
in singapore
i'll be meeting with kim jong-un
to pursue a future of peace
and security for the world for the whole
world
[Music]
in 2018 kim leaves korea for only the
third time as leader
for a historic meeting with president
trump
in singapore
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the singapore summit it really was his
big debut internationally
kim jong-un's coming out
those were incredible scenes
[Music]
i think that's a very telling example of
the image that he wants to portray to
his people
key thing
actually i'm
very charming i'm funny i'm flexible i'm
spontaneous and it's completely
the reverse of what we may have thought
of the north korean leader
[Music]
in singapore north korea's reclusive
dictator takes his first steps on the
world stage
i'm john bolton i was a national
security advisor for president trump
for me it was almost surreal to think
that this was actually happening
a mistake in my view but it was a
historic first
[Music]
[Music]
so
it was very clear in the meeting that
kim was very much in control
he was observing trump very carefully
early in the meeting kim asked trump
what do you think of me
just testing people like that that shows
a level of confidence
i mean what do you think of me as an
invitation to say
you're a tyrannical dictator oppressing
25 million people and i don't trust the
word you say that would have been an
accurate answer but it could have been a
meeting stopper thank you very much
everybody thank you
but of course trump gave him a very
glowing uh review he was smart and so on
and so
mr
forth
excellent relationship thank you
thank you very much
kim comes prepared with a strategy for
dealing with the american president
[Music]
there's a kind of magic that can happen
when these two leaders get together
and i have to say what i saw
it looked like a bromance
[Music]
the north koreans studied whatever they
could to try to understand how president
trump thinks
[Music]
his psychology
how to flatter him
and actually the north koreans know how
to do that very very well
[Music]
kim jong-un sent an envoy with a massive
handwritten letter
north korea is very old school in a
sense uh they're not gonna send email
attachments they're very formal it was
something that charmed president trump
that he got this massive handwritten
letter
[Music]
it was kind of a rambling conversation
i was mostly worried that trump not give
away too much but there was a discussion
about joint south korea and u.s
war games as
trump called them which he agreed to
give up
it was a concession to kim
that none of us on the u.s side knew was
coming okay
it obviously made kim very happy thank
you very much it's fantastic
i was really being tough and so was he
and we'll go back and forth and then we
fell in love okay
no really he wrote me beautiful letters
and they're great letters
we fell in love
[Music]
[Applause]
kim has begun to reinvent himself as a
legitimate world leader
he returns to his people
a conquering hero
the united states is north korea's chief
adversary it is the central enemy
[Music]
so if kim can stand shoulder to shoulder
with the u.s president
that is of itself a kind of victory
[Music]
kim jong-un can tell his people we are
taken seriously by the most powerful
leader
in the world
[Music]
[Applause]
well
[Music]
during the course of 2018
kim jong-un has proven himself to be
very savvy and calculating in the way he
has dealt with the outside world luring
donald trump out
kim jong-un kind of set off a race to to
meet him xi jinping in china
nobody wanted to be left out
we suddenly saw this huge flurry of
summits taking place and it seemed like
all of the leaders wanted to meet with
kim jong-un
north korea is a very impoverished
country
but it has nuclear weapons kim jong-un
can blow up half the planet if he
chooses to in a major war and that's
what gives him an a huge leverage that
otherwise he would never have
[Music]
when he met with putin in russia
putin is very famous for meeting leaders
across the world very very late
well in vladivostok it was putin who
waited for kim jong-un
he wants to show the world that you know
what even between friends
we have the upper hand
but opening his secretive hermit kingdom
to the outside world carries dangers for
kim jong-un
at the start of his rule he encouraged
foreigners to set up businesses in
special trading zones near the chinese
border
[Music]
one of the first outsiders to arrive was
south korean-born u.s citizen kim
dong-chul
indian soil
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
god
[Music]
so
secrets to the cia for four years
before he was betrayed by an informant
and arrested
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
the agent was sentenced to 10 years hard
labor
he had become a pawn in an international
chess game between kim and the west
two years later kim meets with us
hostage negotiators
to build on his warming relationship
with president
trump we do have breaking news right now
president trump tweeting moments ago
that three detained americans have been
released from north korea
vienna
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
in releasing his hostages kim jong-un
bolsters his image as a modern civilized
leader
and buys credit with president trump
i want to thank
kim jong-un who really
was
excellent to
these three incredible people
i really think he wants to do something
and
bring that country into the real world
february
2019 kim jong-un sets out on a 2500 mile
journey
the destination
vietnam
and a second crucial meeting with
president trump
the prize
winning a deal to lift the economic
sanctions crippling his country
[Music]
when he went to hanoi i think he felt
very confident
he very unusually announced through the
state media in north korea that this
summit was going to happen that he
thought this was all going to go very
well for him
you know the stakes were very very high
from kim jong-un's side he wanted to
show his people that you know what
i will make peace with donald trump
i will be the one north korean leader
who shakes hands and signs a deal with
the u.s president
that was the promise kim jong-un made as
he left the train station in pyongyang
[Music]
[Music]
on the first night of the summit the two
leaders meet for a dinner of north
korean steak served well done for trump
and rare for kim
so this was the dinner
before the summit the night before
kim jong-un looks very comfortable and
confident
and he must have put on a bit of a
a show
president trump relayed a story that kim
jong-un told about how
yeah he executed his uncle and then
displayed his head for the rest to see
in this day and age to see that kind of
brutality
very much like the heads of those
beheaded by henry the eighth
were stuck
outside the tower of london
if you could have heard that dialogue
when you would pay for that dialogue
i think it goes to show
that
kim jong-un deep inside
wanted to reach out to donald trump in a
way that no other leader had reached out
to donald trump which is you know what
mr president let's talk about raw power
i will tell you what raw power is
i will give you an example of what i did
to my uncle
donald trump respects raw power and
that's what kim jong-un wanted to
emphasize
a lot of great ideas being thrown about
i think very importantly the
relationship is
you know just very strong
with the dinner table talk out of the
way the two leaders get down to business
analysts say there is considerable
pressure on both trump and kim jong-un
to come up with a more substantive deal
than the one they struck in singapore
kim desperately needs sanctions to be
lifted trump has got to come back with
something more substantive than they got
in june
the north koreans estimated that
president trump needed a foreign policy
victory and that they would sign a deal
kim jong-un thought it was a sure thing
so they got down to the nitty-gritty of
this nuclear deal
but it can quickly go sour
in his opening gambit kim offers a
limited deal
to shut down north korea's largest
nuclear testing site
in return for the complete lifting of
all sanctions
trump was not prepared to make a partial
deal he was prepared to make only the
big deal
which is the complete elimination of
north korea's nuclear weapons program
but kim kept pressing for his more
limited deal
[Music]
like many communist negotiators he's
very good at saying the same thing over
and over again
[Music]
the germans have a word for it they call
it sits fleisch and it means exactly
what it sounds like that he'd just be
prepared to sit there for as long as it
took
so trump and kim went around and around
[Music]
we could see the frustration
that kim felt that he wasn't getting
through
so there came a point where kind of the
silence descended on the room and lasted
and it was at that point i think
everybody realized this meeting is
really over
astonishing the second summit between
the u.s and north korea
is over the headline here no deal the
two leaders motorcades rolled away from
the summit site within minutes of each
other sometimes you have to walk they
literally left a lunch on the table in
hanoi and went off back to their
respective capitals so i think it was a
miscalculation
kim jong was very very sure he could
reach a deal in hanoi so on the long
train ride back to north korea
kim jong-un must have asked himself
who am i going to blame for this failure
who will be the person who will fall by
the sword
kim jong-un was very angry he lost face
and that he didn't have a deal
he left empty-handed
and that has increased the pressure on
kim jong-un since
[Music]
failure to reach a deal with trump is a
major setback in kim's bid to normalize
his regime
at least three of his officials are
thought to have been executed or purged
as punishment
kim was returning to the system of
terror that has sustained his dynasty
for three generations
in north korea the border is not just
solid
it is highly impenetrable
except for the joint security area
where there is no fence
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a north korean soldier called o chung
song the top
soldier in the korean people's army
stationed right along the 38th parallel
only the creme de la creme are posted
along the border
but he dashed across the line
running for his life
he was shot at by north korean guards
[Music]
as the north korean soldier lies wounded
in the demilitarized zone which
separates north and south korea
troops stage a rescue attempt
he was miraculously saved
he was then taken by helicopter to a
korean hospital
it was discovered that there were many
worms in his body
he was a healthy soldier who got the
best treatment in north korea but he was
still suffering from malnutrition
and this was a shock to many people who
are watching
what's happening in north korea
[Music]
this particular video must have shown
kim jong-un that security along the
border was paramount because even the
most trusted lieutenants were ready to
jump ship
i think kim jong-un would have been very
angry at the generals who allowed this
to happen under their watch
and i'm sure they were reprimanded and
imprisoned or even you know
even worse punishment for this
[Music]
to clamp down on a rising tide of
defectors kim has increased border
security and threatened would-be
traitors with severe punishments
[Music]
but the dictator remains torn between
his allegiance to the family dynasty
in the pull of his teenage years in the
democratic west
[Music]
shortly after he took power he tracked
down an old friend in europe
but
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
when you spent your most formative years
in a very westernized country
studying in switzerland as as a teenager
that will stick with you is this
nostalgia
[Music]
field
he will never be able to have their life
back again
but if he invites his childhood friend
to come back to north korea
it's like satisfying a part of his life
that he yearns for
but he can never replay
this
champion
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
kim's two meetings with the u.s
president had failed to deliver a deal
on north korea's nuclear arsenal
in june 2019
trump rekindles the bromance
president trump touching down in south
korea just a short while ago
after having extended an apparently
impromptu invitation to the leader of
north korea
i just put out a a feeler because i i
don't know where he is right now he may
not be in north korea but i said if
chairman kim would want to meet i'll be
at the border certainly
we seem to get along very well
[Music]
the meeting at the dmz was entirely
impromptu
he
tweets an invitation to the north korean
dictator to meet
and north koreans finally do respond and
donald trump marveled that apparently
kim jong-un follows me on twitter
[Music]
after the breakdown of the talks in
hanoi
kim jong-un desperately wants and needs
the opportunity to meet again with
president trump
[Music]
kim jong-un needed some imagery to tell
his people things are fine we're still
friends i've got it under control
the north koreans would have loved
imagery
of kim jong-un slowly making his way to
the demarcation line
president trump was there more quickly
clearly more anxious to cross over to
the north korean side they would have
loved that
the idea that an american president
wants to step into north korean
territory
propaganda gold
suddenly
donald trump is walking
with kim jong-un in north korea
you know the first american leader to
set foot in north korea
[Music]
and then
uh they walked back over to the south
korean side
come on
and we did not know that it was truly
going to happen
and it was a scene of total chaos
[Music]
suddenly it appears that they're going
to be going inside this building and the
north koreans actually try to block
the american press from going over
[Music]
stop press stop
[Music]
[Music]
and so stephanie grisham donald trump's
press secretary
essentially decked a north korean
security guard who is trying to block
the american press from following the
two leaders into this room
[Music]
you know this was an extraordinary photo
op
but
it accomplished absolutely nothing
beyond the photo op
there's no question today's meeting was
an historic first but after two summits
and one impromptu meeting north korea's
nuclear program remains fully in place
with no breakthrough in sight
in the fall of 2019
the dictator changes course
in a symbolic statement to his people he
makes a pilgrimage to the sacred mount
pektu
mythical birthplace of the kim dynasty
[Music]
it's not just that kim jong-un likes
riding horses there's another purpose
here
it is part of the propaganda
[Music]
he's really focused on a particular king
kim dong-myung
and kim jong-un is a warrior who's often
shown fighting off foreign influence and
bringing the country together
on a white horse
and so it's a way to remind his people
that i am the successor of that heritage
and i have a right to rule
turning his back on president trump kim
threatens to deliver a so-called
christmas gift to the united states
jong-un was disappointed he could not
convince mr trump
i think he realized okay
if trump will not negotiate with me
i will make a bigger hammer
[Music]
so that's a message that i think he
wanted to send the world
i will show you how powerful i am
i will show you who's really boss in
this neighborhood
and it's me kim jong-un
[Applause]
october 2020 kim celebrates three
generations of his family's rule
his talks with trump have failed to
remove the sanctions holding back his
economy
how long can he maintain the loyalty of
his people
[Music]
[Music]
in allowing the people to see him cry
kim jong-un on october 10th
wanted to show that he's human too
he wanted to show that vulnerability
yes i am almost like a god and i was
born to lead this country but i'm a
father like you i care about my children
like you i care about our future like
you so it was designed to be a
particular show of humility
and to show his personality
but i can't help but think it's also
theater
and so we are moving into a phase
where we have less access and less
information because it's so carefully
cultivated
they want to
seem like somebody who actually is in
touch with his people
but it's very hard for us to tell
whether we can trust it
[Applause]
economically they're in very very deep
trouble
sanctions
pandemic
and floods
all those problems have combined to make
north korea's economy which was already
on its knees
nearly on its deathbed
and yet kim jong-un
continues to develop nuclear weapons
i think it's very dangerous because if
you are cornered into a position
where there really is no exit
then you might look for extreme
solutions
[Music]
in 2020 kim unveiled the world's largest
mobile intercontinental ballistic
missile
nicknamed
the monster
despite his attempts to modernize north
korea
and remake his image
kim jong-un remains the dictator of a
rogue state that is now more dangerous
than ever
you can't prevent irrational regimes but
you can certainly do everything possible
to keep the world's most dangerous
weapons out of their hands
i think obviously you have to consider
the use of force
i don't think the end of north korea is
likely to be pleasant in any
circumstances
it's thought kim now has at least 40
nuclear missiles
and is close to completing a new secret
weapon that would pose a greater threat
to the west than ever before
[Music]
they're building a new
3 000 ton submarine
with the ability to fire ballistic
missiles
once they reach certain technical
metrics north korea can then put one of
these ballistic missiles on a submarine
[Music]
submarines are very difficult to track
it's basically a roving threat and a
moving target
north korea can then float that
submarine out to the pacific ocean and
scare the crap out of people in los
angeles
[Music]
a whole other mess of stuff to keep
people up at night
[Music]
[Music]
you